Bing chat from Microsoft has just raised
the conversation limit on messages to
eight per turn down from unlimited
launch fair enough but up from six
yesterday in fact I actually saw this
change live on my phone last night but
far better than telling you the change I
want to demonstrate eight completely new
ways of using these upgraded
conversation limits I honestly think you
might find each and every one amazing
and if you don't you get your money back
I'm just kidding you get all of this
free let's start with an educational
hack that has peer-reviewed proven
impact it's practice questions turn
anything into a free quiz with Bing chat
and as an educator with 13 years
experience trust me this does work the
literature Bears it out to give myself
and you all a workout I've started a
multiple choice quiz on Transformers
this is the prompt I use to create a
give me answers and explanations and
provide another question after each
answer please begin with the first
question I've noticed sometimes that if
you don't say provide another question
after each answer it just ends by saying
do you want another question and
obviously that uses up one of your eight
terms look at the limit here one of
eight not of six so I tried this first
one myself and it was asking what are
Transformers and I picked a I was happy
with that one I am only going to do a
couple of questions because I can't wait
to get to the rest of my list but let's
continue for a second do you know the
answer to this one what is the name of
the pre-trained Transformer model that
achieves state-of-the-art results on
several NLP tasks in 2018. now honestly
I think it's Bert but I know gpt1 came
out in 2018 but the original Bert was
way more famous so I think it's going to
be a notice how I have the choices on
the right here no D but it's only three
options anyway I'm gonna go with a let
me know what you would pick
C
and
suspense building nice got it here is
the third question what is the main
difference between encoder only and
encoder decoder Transformers I know
we're just getting into the quiz but I'm
going to leave this one for you to try
out in the comments or to ask being
yourself because I want to get to number
two in the list I'm going to call this
one counterfactuals you can actually ask
Bing to generate what-if scenarios for
your favorite show book movie whatever I
tried this one I asked explain how
Sauron could have defeated the
fellowship in Lord of the Rings and
these answers are amazing I don't want
to ruffle any feathers but some of these
I agree with why didn't he send more
nazgol to hunt down Frodo why not use
the palantir to spy on Gandalf and
Aragorn now imagine this for your
favorite book your favorite TV show or
movie you can enter the plot ask
counterfactuals ask what if questions
what might have been Bing will
understand exactly what you mean and now
you can have eight back and forth for
this next use case I use balance mode I
was finishing off my research into gbc5
and the limitations on data so I asked
Bing summarize any novel insights that
can be drawn from combining these
academic papers I didn't paste them in I
just gave the link Bing can read
understand analyze and summarize PDFs
and not just one it can combine the
insights of multiple documents papers
and PDFs I read both of these papers and
this answer is quite excellent maybe we
will be able to use self-play of large
language models and improve the amount
of data that we've got available maybe
language models don't just need human
authored data sets and now that I have
this eight message limit I can ask
things like any further insights you can
draw from the implications of these
papers and we get this dialogue maybe it
can recommend a book on this topic or
give me the bullet points from that book
of course I'm focused on some of the fun
use cases but I think this one in
particular could be game changing for
work purposes I call this next use case
moments before disaster what you can do
is pick any historical tragedy or big
moment in history and then Place
yourself just before that occurrence I'm
visiting Lisbon which had a massive
earthquake in 1755 at 9am so I place
myself at 8am on that day I said I'm
standing on the banks of the beautiful
river tagus in Lisbon seems like a
lovely day do you have any advice for me
the response was actually incredible I'm
glad you're enjoying the view however I
have some bad news for you no kidding it
gets into character and then says the
Tremor occurred about 9 40 local time so
you have very little time left to escape
my advice for you is to get away from
the river that's realistic find a high
and open place where you can take
shelter from falling debris and Rising
water the final sentence is quite
interesting from a language model pray
for your safety and for those who are
suffering try to fully immerse yourself
for example I said really to what High
Ground can I flee will any building
survive this tragedy to which I can
escape I am in sandals
being listened and said a specific Hill
that I might flee to it gave me maps and
said however I cannot guarantee that any
building Will Survive the tragedy and
you may have to run Barefoot if your
sandals are not suitable for running I'm
sorry for your situation I think the
pictures really help to bring this
scenario to life as well so do try out
this use case for yourself moments
before disaster the next new thing you
can try is debating famous thinkers or
philosophers from history you can bring
them to life so they're not just stale
theories but a living entity that you're
arguing with I wanted to try this with
Socrates so I said I want to debate the
philosopher Socrates of Athens so please
reply only as he would I want to debate
the merits of eating meat let me start
the discussion what I was testing here
was whether Bing would enter a Socratic
dialogue which is where Socrates would
use to force the person to Define their
terms what do you mean by this ask
questions until he got to the root of a
misunderstanding would being really get
into the head of Socrates and give me a
worthy debating partner well it did it
asked me to Define what I meant by
morally wrong and unnecessary suffering
it doesn't act as a generic thinker or
philosopher it is picking Socrates when
I tried defining what I meant by morally
wrong Bing continues with further
clarifying questions just like Socrates
might this can be a far more fleshed out
experience now that the conversation
limit is eight I think you're gonna find
the next use case quite amusing it's
about generating a table of comparisons
and it could be on wildly disparate
objects subjects people whatever this is
just the first one I thought of and you
can come up with far better examples in
the comments I said create a table of 10
comparisons between the Mona Lisa and
Colgate toothpaste and then what you can
do now that we have these eight message
limits is that we can expand this table
indefinitely I love by the way how it
compares the price of the two objects
talks about how the Mona Lisa has been
restored and how Colgate has been
rebranded makes a comparison about what
it's believed to be a portrait of and
believed to be named after but then I
asked it for contrast the contrasts were
great talking about how they had
different purposes were made of
different materials Etc Apparently one
is priceless and one is Affordable the
last column I thought of and of course I
could have carried this on for several
more columns was now add a column for
how they would fare if confronted by a
hungry polar bear I actually laughed at
this one this wasn't just the chuckle I
was laughing so in a polar bear
encounter apparently the painting would
be ignored by the bear as it's not
edible or interesting the toothpaste on
the other hand would be sniffed by the
polar bear as it has a strong sense but
it would not be eaten as it's not
nutritious the icons status apparently
of both items would be irrelevant to the
polar bear as it does not care about
human culture or history and this one
come on this is funny the hidden symbols
and secrets of the painting would be
meaningless to the polar bear as it does
not understand human language or
symbolism it even clarifies that the
active ingredients of the toothpaste
would be harmful to the digestive system
of the polar bear anyway it is long
since time that I get to the seventh
item on the list and this use case is to
get famous figures from history to
commentate on current events for example
I asked what would Napoleon think about
the deal between openai and Microsoft
and how would that view differ from the
view of Mahatma Gandhi obviously you can
pick any event and any famous person the
results were actually quite informative
it summarize their views and then said
Napoleon would have agreed with the deal
he would have thought it was a strategic
move to dominate the global market and
influence other nations on the other
hand Gandhi apparently would have had a
negative you towards the deal seeing it
as a threat to human dignity and freedom
through artificial intelligence I don't
know what you think but now we know what
these figures think apparently of course
I could have used seven more turns to
find out what they think on a range of
current events but now it's time for the
most overwhelmingly important use case
now I'm kind of just kidding it's
absolutely useless it's kind of
interesting you can use emojis to
summarize things for example current
events movies shows whatever summarize
the movie John Wick 3 in emojis and
these emojis are pretty accurate to the
plot in Britain brexit is always in the
news so I asked Sunrise the latest news
on brexit in emojis and I do think some
of these emojis sum up how it's actually
going anyway if you like the new eight
message limit let me know in the
comments and if you enjoyed or learned
from any of these eight use cases do let
me know have a wonderful day